(birds chirping)
(deep breathing)
- Hey Martin.
- Hey, how did you
know it was me?
- I know every creak
in these floor boards,
I'm one with this house.
What could I do for you?
- I know I'm new here but my
parents are visiting later
and I was wondering if maybe
we could address the smell?
- What smell?
- The smell, it's like
rotten eggs in a locker room.
- I haven't left the
house in 16 days.
- Maybe just stick your
head outside the window
for a second and then.
- Okay.
(sniffs)
(vomiting)
- Oh!
Oh yeah.
Yeah, there's
definitely a smell,
it's like a stir fry of dicks.
Okay, tell your parents
to take the long way.
We're gonna stink hunting.
(intense music)
- Chug, chug, chug, go Nick!
- Ha ha, Nick.
- Hey Cal.
- [Cal] Hey.
- Martin
- Hey man, you smell that smell?
Martin found it.
- Oh yeah, I actually
found it before Martin did
and I was gonna say
that, we should,
what, what do you
wanna do about it?
- Well let's go find it!
- Yes, mission!
Wooh!
- What, what's that bong?
Oh, you want me to take deep
long tokes of your dank buds?
Alright bro, you asked for it!
- Cornell, Betsy, something
smells like (mumbling) underwear
and we have to find it.
- Yeah, well I'm not
smelling for jill squat
until I'm done with
my workout, alright?
(grunting)
This is your face Cal!
Yeah, yeah!
Ugh, alright, let's do this,
you're not the boss of me.
- Hey man, you know I'm down.
Just gonna stash the
munchies for later.
(sniffing)
- Hey, what's going on bros?
Doing some sniffing?
I guess I could get the
old nose out of retirement.
Or we could watch a movie.
I tried to rent, In the Bedroom
but I got, The Room.
That movie is good.
- Guys, I think I found it.
(vomiting)
What have you done to
our secondary bathroom?
- [Guy Roommate 1] That's
my secondary kitchen!
- [Girl Roommate 1]
My walk in hamper!
- Guys, we're gonna need
to clean this, today.
Der, luckily we could
just spin the chore wheel.
I figured out, it's right here.
Let's give it a little spin.
Oh my god!
(screaming)
That was my grandma's
chore wheel.
- Okay, we have a back up plan.
Remember, we put the apartment
chart on the Olf poster
and it says,
"he who cleaned last must
choose his or her successor".
- Okay, so who cleaned last?
- I did, you guys made
me clean when I moved in.
- Martin gets to choose.
(dramatic music)
- Um, I guess I'll go inside
and see who made the mess
and then we'll go from there.
- Yeah, good idea, great idea.
- Great idea.
- Good idea
- It's a wonderful idea.
- Good idea.
- Guys, I think I'm
gonna help him out.
Marty, let me lay down
the law for you here.
There's six people in this house
and the only way it all works
is with a clear
chain of command.
If me, our leader appears weak,
the whole system collapses,
do you get what I'm saying?
- That you don't want
me to pick you to clean.
- I didn't say that.
Did you fart?
- Guys, Cal's been in there
for 45 seconds with Martin.
Something is happening, we
need to forge an alliance.
- So, when they tell us to clean
we're like, no way?
That's so tight.
- Listen Cal, you're my
best friend of all time
that's why you need to know
that there's talk of
an alliance out there.
- Alliance?
They want an alliance,
they're gonna get one from us.
- Hey.
- Yeah?
- Can it just be you and me?
- No that's stupid.
- What the?
Cornell,
that backstabbing sack.
Alright, you and I, we
have got to become allies.
- Oh, we're not so
different you and I.
- No.
(laughing)
- Look man, I don't know
what you're going to say
but I plan on being fair.
- Oh hey man, what's up?
What's up!
(laughing)
- I don't know who
to trust anymore man,
it's like everything
is falling apart.
- Trust me.
- Forever.
- You want me as an ally
- Okay.
- You want me as an ally.
- Oh I've always
wanted you as an ally
- I can protect you
- Would you like to
dance with the devil?
- I'll dance with you
until the day I die.
- What the hell was that about,
I thought we had an alliance?
- No, no, no listen baby.
- I wanna be with you.
- Prove it, let me eat
a tiny piece of you.
- I have your son.
- Give him back.
- He just said he has my son.
- I don't care
who's got your son.
- I don't even have a son.
- We had an alliance.
- I wanna raise
a child with you.
(talking over each other)
- What's up!
You guys remember that?
(everyone agreeing)
- That's a great one,
it's a great commercial.
- What are you doing?
Get off of him!
(screaming)
- Hey guys.
Look, it's not that bad okay?
I'll just clean it myself.
- Oh
- That's convenient.
- What a hero.
- I'll clean the bathroom now.
- Who's the smart guy now?
- [Cal] I got the
plunger, I win!
(vomiting)